[Music]
the loki finale just blew up the mcu
we are now in full-on multiverse
territory as teams in avengers end game
and one division
eager marvel fans have long expected
this with spider-man no way home
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
and ant-man and the wasp quantomania
guaranteeing that we'll be seeing some
major timeline shenanigans in
mcu phase 4. loki however has finally
shown us how the multiverse can exist
in the finale we finally meet he who
remains a godlike figure who we discover
created the tva and is a true protector
of the sacred timeline
this timeline is destroyed though when
sylvie driven by revenge for being taken
by the tva as a child
kills he who remains creating endless
branches and truly cracking the
multiverse
wide open he who remains as played by
the enormously talented jonathan mages
it was first reported by deadline in
september 2020
that mages was cast as iconic marvel
villain kang the conqueror
and would be appearing in ant-man and
the wasp quantomania
in the comics he who remains and kang
the conqueror are different characters
but the mcu has merged the two as anyone
who saw the episode could attest
mage's performance as kang and loki was
certainly seen stealing and his previous
performances are equally as captivating
we just crossed the threshold
audiences likely know majors best from
his work on hbo's lovecraft country
based on the novel of the same name by
matt ruff mages plays atius freeman
a young man traveling 1950s america in
search of his missing father
not only does atticus have to overcome
the fierce racism in jim crow era
america
but some terrifying monsters said to
have inspired the iconic hp lovecraft
novels
lovecraft country was cancelled by hbo
but earned an impressive 18 nominations
at the 2021 emmys including outstanding
drama series
and outstanding lead actor for mages in
a statement responding to the
nominations as reported by indiewire
major said
thank you for seeing the light in the
dark and the smile and the tears of this
character
atticus freeman he is one of my best
friends and i'm glad you all got to meet
him as well
playing this role has changed my life
and this nomination is yet
another growing and changing moment
lovecraft country may have been mage's
breakout role but the performer has
shown his talents before
mages also starred in the 2017 abc
miniseries when we rise
a chronicled retelling of the gay rights
movement in the united states
mages portrays a young version of real
life lgbtq activist
ken jones an early advocate in
preventing the spread of hiv
particularly among gay black men on
playing such an important figure in the
gay rights movement
mages told w magazine my politics have
become very clear
and they've come to the surface of who i
am as a human being it's so rare to do a
piece where you don't have to separate
your politics and your work and your art
mages has also been praised for his work
in the a24 film
the last black man in san francisco
another overtly political project the
film follows a young black man's efforts
to reclaim his childhood home in gender
fried san francisco
written by and starring jimmy fails it's
a semi-autobiographical recount of
fail's own quest
to overcome the devastating impacts of
gentrification
major stars as montgomery allen bale's
best friend
the characters bond as a key component
of the story and talking with the
hollywood reporter
major shared that the actors connected
off-screen too mages told the outlet
there were deep things that were going
on in phil's life that we would just sit
and have breakfast and talk about
things that i've experienced what it is
to be young gifted and black or in my
case
young kind of gifted and black issues of
trying to be a young man in the world
he's my buddy he's my best friend the
last black man in san francisco
premiered at the 2019
sundance film festival and earned
director joe talbert both the u.s
dramatic directing award
and a special drawing award barack obama
also named it as one of his favorite
films of 2019
audiences may also know mages from his
work on white boy rick
starring matthew mcconaughey and set in
1980s detroit at the height of the war
on drugs the film follows a blue-collar
father
and his teenage son rick based on a true
story
rick becomes the fbi's youngest ever
drug informant at age 14
and quickly finds himself immersed in
the lucrative world of drug dealing
major stars as johnny curry a local
kingpin who brings rick into his fold of
illegal activities
the actor talked to the source about how
he hopes the film would challenge
people's perception of drug dealers
calling his character a leader of men he
elaborated
saying that's something we miss when
we're dealing with african-american drug
dealers it's an occupation he could be a
lawyer or doctor and have the same
attributes it's just the fact that he's
a drug dealer it's easy to write him off
with his career still in its early
stages and already having a slew of
impressive roles behind him
jonathan mages is ready for more success
the ending of the first loki season is
just one sign of greater things to come
for him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one